[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم واقدم اليكم العربيه 360 حيث الخبر
من كل زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
من التجديد النصفي حتى الرئاسه بيدن خاسر
سعيد وترامب رابح حزين ونيويورك غيرت
جلدها
حان موعد القسط الثاني لفاتوره دعم اكياس
اضراب يشل باريس جزئيا ولندن تواجه خطر
غلقي مشافها
اطباء ايران في صدام مكتوم مع الامن رفض
روايه وفاه مهس امين واخفى هويات مصابين
تظاهرات
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا
[موسيقى]
اسبوع جنوني للعمولات المشفره تناطح اكبر
من السطين يبخر المليارات وشبح لمن
برادورز يحوم حول الجميع
[موسيقى]
في انتخابات التجديد النصفي الامريكيه لم
يكن غريبا ان يشيد الرئيس بيضا
بالانتخابات باعتبارها يوما جيدا
للديمقراطيه فالنتائج اسعدته ولم يكن
غريبا ايضا ان يبدي استعداده للتعاون مع
الجمهوريين لان سيطرتهم القريبه على
النواب ستسعجه لكن في المقابل كانت تشديده
على ان مستقبل الولايات المتحده لا يجب ان
يكون اسير حرب سياسيه لا نهايه لها هو
الغريب فالحرب بدات بالفعل لم يتغير
توقيتها وانما ستتغير حدتها وربما
اللاعبون
[موسيقى]
ونبدا اولا بالوقوف على اخر تحديث لنتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه في مجلس
النواب ووفقا لشبكه سي ان ان حصل جمهوريون
حتى الان على 2009 مقاعد في ما حصد
الديمقراطيون على 192 مقعدا وتتوقع سي ان
ان يحصد الجمهوريون 16 مقعدا اضافيا ليصل
الاجمالي الى 225 مقعدا بينما سيصل عدد
مقاعد الديمقراطيين الى 295 اما بشان
المنافسه في مجلس الشيوخ والتي لم تحسم
نهائيا بعد فقد حصد الجمهوريون 49 مقعدا
فيما حصد الديمقراطيون ثمانيه واربعين
مقعدا
اين كانت اقصى الضربات للمعسكر الديمقراطي
تحديدا اكمل الحزب او ضمن ربما ولاء ولايه
نيويورك لتاريخها الليبرالي فلم يصب
تركيزه عليها لتاتي الضربه الاقوى منها
الحصن الديمقراطي المنيع نيويورك قلبت
الطاوله على حزبها واهداف الجمهوريين
اربعه مقاعد في الكونغرس وهو اكبر عدد من
المقاعد يخسرها الديمقراطيون في اي ولايه
على الاطلاق عبر الترويجي لمخاوف زياده
التضخم وانتشار الجريمه تغلغل الجمهوريون
وكسبوا اصوات الناخبين في ضواحي ايلاند
وحتى جيو بروكلينز حيث فاز بسهوله
في الناخبين المتعلقه بالسلامه هو سياسه
عامه سيئه ادت الى خسائر متعدده كان يمكن
تجنبها
واضاف ان هذه الخسائر سيكون لها تاثير
سلبي للغايه ليس فقط على نيويورك ولكن على
ميزان القوه في البلاد حصاد الجمهوريون
اذا جائزه مذهله هزيمه النائب شون
باتريكمالوني رئيس حمله الديمقراطيين في
مجلس النواب المكلف بحمايه سيطره حزبه على
الكونجرس لكن ما حدث والذي هز قبضه
الديمقراطيين فعلا لم يؤثر على منصب
الحاكم الذي فازت به كافي هوكول بفارق خمس
نقاط على النائب الجمهوريه لزالدن المدعو
من ترامب تنقل صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن
هاوردن احد الاستراتيجيين الديمقراطيين
البرازيين قوله ملخصا خيبه امل حزبه لقد
كانت ليله مروعه في نيويورك من سيتحكم في
الكونغرس تشير نتائج الى ان مجلس النواب
يميل نحو الجمهوريين لكن الامر لم يحسن
بعد اذ يمكن ان تساعد بطاقات الاقتراع
البريديه المتاخره الديمقراطيين اكتر لكن
سيستغرق ذلك عده ايام اما مجلس شيوخ
فستحتدم المعركه في ثلاث ولايات هي نيفادا
وجورجيا واريزونا فرز الاصوات المعلقه في
نيفادا واريزونا قد يستغرق اياما ايضا لكن
السيطره ستحسمها جورجيا التي تتجه الى
جوله الاعاده في السادس من ديسمبر المقبل
[موسيقى]
العمل
وفي بني وفرشادير
[موسيقى]
صحيح ان الجمهوريين كسبوا في نيويورك
لكنهم خسروا في كثير من الولايات السبب
ترامب ومرشحوها او هكذا يرى على الاقل
انصار وقادت الحزب الذين وجهوا سيلا من
الانتقادات والاتهامات للرئيس السابق
الرئيس الخامس والاربعون بات تحت النار
داخل حسبه تنقل صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن
ديفيد اوربن مستشار ترامب السابق قوله ان
الجمهوريين اتبعوا دونالد ترامب الذي
اوصلهم الى حافه الهاويه ينظر الى ترامب
الى حد بعيد على انه المسؤول عن النهايه
المخيبه للجمهوريين في انتخابات الثلاثاء
اذ هزم عدد كبير من المرشحين الذين ادهم
بمن في ذلك المرشحون لمنصب الحاكم ومجلس
الشيوخ في ولايه بنسلفانيا وحكام ولايه
مشجن نيويورك
كينج لونج ايلندا والذي دعم ترامب منذ
فتره طويله قال انه لا ينبغي ان يكون
ترامب وجه الحزب الجمهوري في 20 24 مضيفا
ان الحسبه لا يمكن ان يتمحور حول فرد واحد
[موسيقى]
في كل الاحوال كشف الهجوم الذي على الرئيس
السابق عبر قناه فوكس وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعيه ان ترامب في الضعف في نقطه له
من الناحيه السياسيه منذ هجوم السادس من
يناير 20 21 على مبنى الكابيتل
عليه
لانهم دفعوه لتاييده الرجل
السابق قال على قناه اي بي سي ان ترامب
اظهر مره اخرى ان اختياراته السياسيه لا
تتعلق بالحزب ولا تتعلق بالبلد بل تتعلق
به شخصيا او بالاحرى بمصالحه الخاصه
الامر يتطور فقط جينز المستشار السابق
لنجما كانل زعيم الاقليه الجمهوريه في
مجلس الشيوخ ان يكون الرانده حاكم فلوريدا
او لنكن
لين عن ترامب في انتخابات 20 و24 بينما
قالت كيلي ما كناني السكرتاريه صحفيه
سابقه للبيت الابيض في اداره ترامب على
قناه فوكس نيوز ان رئيسها السابق يجب ان
يتاخر عن الاعلان الذي تحدث عنه والمفترض
يوم الخامس عشر من نوفمبر وعليه الانتظار
الى حين يحسن نتائج ولايه جورجيا التي
تشهد لاعاده في السادس من ديسمبر كما قلنا
اذا يرى بعض الجمهوريين ان ترامب قوض فرص
الحزب في الانتخابات النصفيه وكان السبب
رئيس في منع حدوث فيما جرى ما جرى التروي
له من قدوم الموجه الحمراء
متابعه لكل ذلك معنا من واشنطن مراسله
العربيه ناديه البلبيسي من نيفادا مراسله
العربيه ريتا سليمان ومن جورجيا مراسل
العربيه حسين الطود اهلا بكم جميعا وابدا
معك همم ناديه همم كيف يمكن اسقاط ما
ذكرناه كل ما ذكرناه منذ بدايه العربيه
360 هذه
على الارض ما المحددات التي افرزتها هذه
الانتخابات ان كان مقارنه بالانتخابات
السابقه خاصه على صعيد مجلس النواب او همم
تشرفا لما هو قادم في العامين الحاسمين
المقبلين قبل الرئاسيات
ثاني
ا
ضعف الرئيس ترامب ثلاث عوامل اثرت بشكل
كبير بالنسبه للناخب الامريكي كنا نتحدث
على ان الاقتصاد هو العنوان الاساسي لهذه
الانتخابات وبالفعل يعني هناك ارتفاع
لاسعار المحروقات والمواد الغذائيه
ونسبه تضخم عاليه وكساد رغم ان البيت
الابيض ينكر بان البلاد ستذهب في كساد لكن
رغم ذلك كان البيت الابيض يركز دوما على
موضوع الديمقراطيه حتى ان الرئيس
فقط ليتحدث على ان الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
في خطر وبان هذه الديمقراطيه خطوطت من قبل
مؤيدين رئيس ترامب الذي وصفهم البيت
الابيض بانهم فاشين ونازيين وهو استخدام
قاسي جدا البعض انتقدوا لكن في النهايه
يبدو بان الناخب الامريكيه يهتم
بديمقراطيه حتى اكثر من يعني معيشته
وارتفاع الاسعار والى اخره البيت الابيض
بالفع يشعر بالرضا لان حتى لو الجمهوريين
سيطروا على المجلس هي هذه هي وانتصار بطعم
الهزيمه طاير ومن هنا اعتقد بانه الناخب
الامريكي اثبت مره اخرى بانه استطلاعات
الراي لا يمكن الاعتماد عليها وبانه
بالنهايه يهتم بمستقبل بلده ومستقبل
اجياله وطبعا الان نبدا بعمليه مراجعه
لدور الرئيس ترامب الذي يقول البعض بانه
اخس او همم ادى الى خساره الجمهوريه في
البيت الابيض في الانتخابات السابقه 2020
وفي انتخابات الكونجرس في السابق ايضا في
عهده والان رغم حتى اذا كان هناك فوز على
افضل الاحوال كان على الجمهوريين ان
ينتزعوا مجلس الشيوخ باغلبيه على الاقل 5
مقاعد هم خسروا بنسلفانيا التي اشارت
اليها التي كان فيها سنه الجمهوري وخسروا
الحكم فيها وائل اخي وبالتالي الان همم
بدا البعض يقول بان بالفعل ترامب جريح كان
المفروض ان كون الجريح هو رئيس بايدل
والبعض كان يهمس ويقول بانه حان الوقت
لرئيس بايدن لان يعلن بانه لن يترشح لي
ولايه ثانيه بالامس راينا العكس يعني
انقلبت الاوراق الرئيس بيدر قال بانه يمكن
ان يترشح لم يحسم القرار قلب انه قرار
عائلي وطبعا سياخذ هذا عن الاعتبار في
بدايه العام القادم لكن تاكد بانه سيكون
هناك تحدي
لزعامه الرئيس ترامب للحزب الجمهوري والان
بدات هذه القبضه تتفكر وسنرى اصوات تطالب
بابعاد الرئيس ترامب وترامبيه اذا اردت عن
الحزب الجمهوري التقليدي شكرا على كل هذه
التوضيحات ناديه دعينا همم نرى اذا كان
ذلك ينطبق على همم هذا حيث اريد سليمان
مراسله همم العربيه همم ريتا الكلمه لكي
الان نيفادا كان لها خصوصيه همم في هذه
الانتخابات ونتائج متاخره همم فبالتالي هل
هي نفس الاسباب وكيف تعيش بعد ايامها
الاولى بعد هذا التاخر
اه نيفادا على ما يبدو تتحول الى اللون
الاحمر طاهر مع احتساب او جرد حوالي 83%
من الاصوات حتى اللحظه
وبتثبت هذه الاصوات بتقدم المرشحين
الجمهوريين ان كان على مقعد حاكم الولايه
لمبردو حصل على 50 فاصل واحد في المئه
بينما المرشح الجمهوري على مقعد الحاكم
عفوا المرشحه الديمقراطي على مقعد حاكم
الولايه سيسولك حصل على سته واربعين فاصل
اثنين في المئه في ما خص مجلس الشيوخ تقدم
ايضا للمرشح الجمهوري ادم لاكسالته واخذ
49.4 في المئه همم ضد منافساته
الديمقراطيه
التي اخذت حوالي 47.6
عمليه جلد الاصوات تتم حتى اللحظه في
المركز الرئيسي في شمال
حيث وصلت كل الاصوات من كل المراكز في
مقاطعه كلارك كاونتي والشير انه هذه
المقاطعه تحوي حوالي 75% من الكثافه
السكانيه في ولايات نيفادا تقدم فيها كان
للمرشحه الديمقراطيه عن مجلس الشيوخ ولكن
الكلمه الفصل والتي سمح بتقدم الجمهوريين
اتت من بقيه المقاطعه همم في همم نيفادا
غير متفاجئه يعني لانه كنت يعني على ما
اذكر تنقلين مثل هذه التوجهات للناخب
الامريكي في يوم الاقتراع
صحيح
صحيح والسبب تاخر اعلان النتائج حتى
اللحظه هو سبب تقني وقانوني بحث لانه هذه
هي المره الاولى نيفادا تستخدم او تسمح
بالتصويت عبر البريد من الخارج وعندما
اتصلنا بها مركز جرد الاصوات سالنا عن سبب
التاخر وقالوا لنا انه السبب بانه هذه هي
المره الاولى التي يتم فرزها الاصوات عبر
البريد من الخارج لذلك تتاخر النتيجه حتى
يوم الجمعه ربما دون تاكيد ذلك مائه في
المئه ولكن المعركه الحاسمه في اريزونا
همم طاهر اذا سمحت لي همم اريزونا يبدو
المتوجهها ازرق همم ان كان على مجلس
الشيوخ او الحاكم مجلس همم الشيوخ تم حصد
او شهر 70% من الاصوات حتى اللحظه التقدم
للمرشح الديمقراطيه
همم تم فرز 979 ااه
1509 اصوات همم ما يعني خدموا همم 51.4 في
المئه ضد المرشح الجمهوري بلاك ماسترز
الذي همم حصل على
884,191 اي
46.4% من مجمل الاصوات يجب ان نذكر هنا
بانه لا زال هناك حوالي 600,000 صوت يتم
فرزهم في مقاطعه ماري كوبا كاونتي بسبب
العطل التقني اذا ما تذكرنا يوم
الانتخابات والذي ادى الى توقف حوالي 20%
من مراكز الاقتراع لهذا السبب تم همم همم
ازاحه 600 الف
332,000 يساوي كم احتسابهم من اصل 600 الف
حتى هذه الساعه هناك تقدم للمرشحين تمام
الديمقراطيه ايضا في مجلس الشيوخ منصب
الحاكم اذا نتحدث عن نتائج محسومه عن
نتائج متاخره وعن نتائج بحاجه الى اعاده
همم ك يخبرنا اكثر حسين التوت خاصه في
جورجيا في انتخابات السادس ااه جوله
الاعاده في السادس من ديسمبر المقبل حسين
هل همم تلحظ بانه نفس العوامل همم
والمحددات التي عمل عليها المرشحون
والحسبان بشكل اساسي في الفتره الماضيه
سيستمر العمل بها طيله الفتره المقبله حتى
جوله الاعاده يعني لا بد انهم الانتخابات
ستصبح حمله الوطيس اكثر بين المرشحين
بالفعل طاهر هذا ماشي ادعوا الان على حمله
فعلا بدات بوضع استراتيجيه لكيف سوف ستقوم
بتحضير اكثر كمان بالتحضير لجوله الاعاده
قرش الموفر اعلنت انها جمعت منذر البارحه
الى اليوم الخامس 3
ملايين دولار و3000 دولار 10 300,000
دولار وتحدثت واتمنى ان ياتي الى هنا
الرئيس هل يساعدان الوكر في حملته عدد من
اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الجمهوريين على راسه
يمتلكوز الذي وصل اليوم الى جورجيا
سيتوافدون الى هذه الولايه لدعم مرشحيا
الجمهوريه عرش الوطن هناك حماس همم
قالت انها ستقوم بحملات عديده على المناطق
الماهوله من جورجيا من اجل همم داعميه
ترامب وهو ايديه ترامب وايضا من وصفاتهم
بالجمهوريين المعتمدين اضافه الى مؤيدين
المرشحه الثالث للانتخابات ايضا
تتحدث بسته ملايين دولار من اجل همم دوله
الاعاده وايضا همم كان هناك هجوم من قبل
على مناف جمهوريه عرس الوكر قال انها همم
نواقر ليس مؤهلا لهذا المنصب الذي يتطلب
همم المعرفه الكبيره وايضا الاستماع وفهم
الناس اذا نحن على على على يعني على ابواب
الحمله شديده الوطاس هناك ستكون معركه
حاميه انا لا شك من ظل هذا التجاذب وتدل
على الانقسام هنا الكل يريد ان يحصل هذه
هذا المقعد كمان بدنا نعلم هذا المقعد هو
من سيقرر من سيسيطر على مجلس الشيوخ هذا
من السبب نرى هذا الحماس نرى هذا دفع
بالاموال همم
استثمارات بملايين الدولارات من اجل
يكون منافس له ولكنه فشل ايضا
جمهور ومعه جمهوريون يقول انه ارناف همم
وهو في منصبه لم يستطع ان يحصل المنافسه
في هذا هو غير مؤهل لينكسر في جوله
الاعاده لا خطاب تظهر مدى التنافس ومدى
احتدام الصراع بين الطرفين شيء متى همم
واضحا ومتى منطقيا كما قلنا هذه هي
المعركه الحاسمه جورج هي همم ساحه
الانتخابات الحاسمه التي ستتحدد من سيطر
على مجلس الشيوخ معلومات كثيره ومهمه همم
شكرا جزيلا انا متاكد انه حكيته اكثر من
كل المرشحين في الانتخابات الامريكيه في
هذين يومين فقط ههه شكرا جزيلا لكم
التركيز بالكامل منصب على نتيجه مجلسي
الشيوخ والنواب لكنه هناك نتيجه اخرى
تحتاج لالقاء الضوء عليها حكام وسكر
الولايات لا ننسى ان منصب حاكم الولايه
كان نقطه انطلاق 17 رئيسا لدخول المكتب
البيضاوي اي ان 40% من من حكموا الولايات
المتحده كانوا في الاصل حكاما لولايات
نتحدث عن بلتون جورج بوش الابن رونالدو
الجمهوري الذي لم يحدث في النواب والشيوخ
بالتاكيد لم يحدث ايضا في 36 ولايه اختارت
حكمها الجدد لكن ما اهميه دور حكام
الولايات في الواقع معظم الامريكيين
يرتبطون بحكوماته ولاياتهم ويتواصلون معها
اكثر من اتصالهم بالحكومه الفيدراليه لان
ادارات الشرطه والمكتبات والمدارس تخضع
لاشراف الاولى
يتمتع غالبيه الحكام بسلطه تعيين قضاه
محاكم الولايات ايضا كما ان لهم سلطه
الدعوه لجلسات تشريعيه خاصه ويتمتعون كذلك
بسلطه استخدام حق النقض الفيتو ضد
الاجراءات التشريعيه برمتها
وهناك ايضا اهميه اخرى كبيره للادارات
المحليه للولايات فروما ان سباق
لانه يقع على عاتق مسؤولين الولايات
والمسؤولين المحليين الاشراف على
الانتخابات واجراءات التصديق على نتائجها
وعلى عكس انتخابات الرئاسه التي تختار
خلالها الولايات ممثليها في المجمع
الانتخابي حيث يتم التصديق على النتائج من
قبل كونغرس يتم اعتماده النتائج النهائيه
في سباقات مجلس النواب والشيوخ في كل
ولايه على حده والعديد من الولايات لديها
سكرتير منتخب يمثل اعلى سلطه في
الانتخابات وهو الذي يصادق على النتائج
اذا رئيس دوله الامارات بحث عن نتنياهو
صبل تحقيق السلام في المنطقه وفقا لوكاله
الانباء الاماراتيه نتابع في موضوع
الانتخابات الامريكيه من واشنطن دكتور
فراس مقصد استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه جورج واشنطن اهلا بك معنا مره جديده
دكتور فراس كنا نسال زملائنا المراسلين
على الارض ما المحددات التي لعبت الدوري
الابرز في هذه النتائج لانه قبل
الانتخابات كنا نسال عن استطلاعات وعن
التوقعات الان بدنا امام امر واقع
فبالتالي ما ابرز هذه المحددات وكيف سيكون
تاثيرها هل ستبقى كما هي في السباق نحو
الرئاسه بعد عامين
مساء الخير ظهر لك كل الجمهور الكريم ااا
نعم اعتقد من الواضح ان دائما نحن نقول في
الولايات المتحده ان الاقتصاد هو العام
الاول وكل الترجيحات كانت تشير الى ذلك
بالاخص ما نمو يعني نسبه التضخم هي نسبه
تاريخيه في طريقه المعاصر للولايات
المتحده تتدمر كبير لدى الامريكيين من هذا
التضخم وغلاء الاسعار وهذا تاثير سلبي
طبعا للحزب الحاكم الحزب الديمقراطي
وايجابي للحزب الجمهوري ولكن المفاجاه
كانت وكل المفاجاه ان فعلا
موضوع الاجهاض وموضوع حقوق المراه اثبت
انهم موضوع اساس لدى النائب الامريكي
وبالاخص النساء هنا في الولايات في
الولايات المتحده واستطاعات الراي لم يعني
لم تعطي اهميه كافيه لهذا الموضوع
والكثيرين يعني بلاش نحلل ما يسمى
من الواضح ان الكثير من النساء اصوات في
الضواحي ضواحي المدن التي كانت ممكن ان
تذهب جمهوريا ذهب الديمقراطيه فالاختصار
وموضوع حقوق المراه والاجهاض هم العوامل
الاساسيه طبعا هنالك التركيز كان من الحزب
الجمهوري على موضوع الهجره الغير الشرعيه
تفلت الحدود مع دوله المكسيك والهجره
الغير شرعيه الى الولايات المتحده طبعا
موضوع الامن وما يسمى
يعني سحب الاموال من الشرطه الذي كثيرين
بالحزب الديمقراطي كانوا يحبون ذلك هذه
المواضيع لم تكن اساسيه بما كانت تشير
اليه باذن الله
من خلال كل همم القوانين التي مررها
بالفعل في الفتره الاخيره في الكونجرس وهي
ب 100 مليارات الدولارات وفي اكثر من مجال
هل تاخر بها ان الظروف يعني فاقت كل ما
استطاع فعله
هنالك التاريخ للانتخابات النصفيه في
الولايات المتحده وغالبا لم يكن دائما
الحزب الحاكم يخفى في الانتخابات النصفيه
عندما كان الرئيس اوباما هو في البيت
الابيض كانت الخساره مدويه كان هناك خساره
65 مقعدا للحزب الحاكم الحزب الدكران
الديمقراطي وقتها وعندما كان بالكلندن احد
لا ربما اكثر ال- ال- الرؤساء المعاصرين
همم شعبيا كانت هنالك اكثر من 50 54 مقعدا
خساره للحزب الحاكم معظم الاميركيين
يفضلون ان يكون هنالك مساءله في اداره
شؤونهم في واشنطن اي ان يكون في البيت
الابيض ومن يتحكم بالكونغرس حزب مختلفان
همم ويكون هناك مساءله في كيفيه اداره
شؤونهم العامه في واشنطن واعتقد هذا همم
ما راينا طبعا هنالك حدا من هذه الخساره
اعتقد ان خطاب الرئيس
همم في الامس اظهر انه الى حد ما هو خساره
بطعم نجاح هو حد من هذه الخساره كانت
خساره المتوقعه هي اكبر بكثير من ما حصل
دكتور هل توافق على يعني مقوله ان بيدن لم
يسقط ترامب فقط في 2020 انما اسقطه في 20
22 ايضا ولو ان الجمهوريين فازوا في
النواب وربما حتى يفوزون في الشيوخ الا ان
ترامب نفسه مع مؤيديه قد يكون اسقط بالفعل
وهذا ما قد سيؤثر على
حظوظوظه في انتخابات 20 24 اذا قرر همم
الترشح على الاقل يمكن ان نقول همم يعني
وفقا لهذه ال- ال- المقوله والاعتبارات
بان بيض والحزب الديمقراطي فتح صراعا شرسا
في داخل خصمه الحزب الجمهوري من الان وحتى
20 24 على الاقل بعد ساعه على سبيل المثال
من المبكر يا طاهر من الممكن ان نقول ان
الرئيس السابق ترام كان خسر هذه المعرفه
اعتقد نعم هو كان هناك الكثير من الخسائر
الكثير من المرشحين الذي دعامهم لم ينجحوا
في الانتخاب ولكن كان هنالك البعض الذي
نجح ولكن الاهم من ذلك والمفارقه هنا ان
سيكون هنالك تاثير كبير ما زال للرئيس
ترامب على ليس فقط الناخب الامريكي ولكن
ده داخل الحسبه الجمهوري نحن نعلم ان كيف
هو يطمح ان يكون رئيس الاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب هو يحتاج لكل اصوات لانه الغالبيه
الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب ستكون ضئيله جدا
ممكن حتى بس خمس مقاعد او عشر مقاعد همم
فالكام او الفريق الذي يؤيد ترامب داخل
الحزب الجمهوري ممكن ان همم يلقي بالثقه
مع او ضد همم كابل مكارثي وهو يحتاج لكل
صوت ممكن ان يحصل عليه داخل داخل الحز
جمهورك ضف الى ذلك طبعا ان اا اذا كان دو
سانتوس او غير دو سانتوس هم بحاجه للرئيس
واصوات ومقيديه مقيديه الرئيس ترامب لكي
ينجحوا في اي انتخابات رئاسيه مقبله اعتقد
دعم الحزب جمهوري مقدم على الكثير من
المشاكل والصراعات الداخليه ممكن ان تنعكس
هذا بينعكس سالبا جدا على السباق المحبوب
في جورجيا اعاده همم التصويت في جورجيا في
في ديسمبر لنرى ان اذا سيكون هنالك اتفاق
ولكن ربما المشكله الاساسيه او العائق
الاساسي للرئيس السابق ترامب النادي
سانتوس رامدس
وولايات اداره ستكون هي ولايه اساسيه في
اي طامح للبيت الابيض في سن همم 24
كالعاده في راس مقصد العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه جورج واشنطن شكرا جزيلا على هذه
المشاركه دكتور
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا في
اوروبا لا يهم ما يقوله الساسه عن التضحيه
من اجل اوكرانيا الاهم موقف من يدفعون
الثمن مطربون وغاضبون
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
على مختلف الدول الاوروبيه و يوما بعد اخر
تزداد الظلال قتامه موجه الاضرابات انتشرت
في عده دول بسبب ارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه
وارتفاع اسعار الطاقه قبل ايام في بلجيكا
وامس في اليونان اليوم اغلق عمال مترو
الانفاق نصف خطوط مترو باريس في يوم اضراب
عام واحتجاجات امتدا للمعلمين ولهيئات
حكوميه اخرى الهدف مطالبه الحكومه وارباب
العمل بزياده الرواتب لمواكبه التضخم الذي
فجرته الحرب في اوكرانيا سكان باريس كانوا
مستعدين على ما يبدو لهذا اليوم استخدم
الدراجات او استقل الحافلات للوصول الى
اعمالهم بينما فضل بعضهم العمل عن بعد
في فرنسا الى اجراءات نقابيه متعدده في
الاشهر الاخيره اثرت على سير الحياه
اليوميه في البلاد
في الشهر الماضي تسبب اضراب عمال مصافي
النفط في نقص الوقود وحينها تدخلت الحكومه
لاجبارهم على العوده الى العمل بعد التوصل
الاتفاق بشان الاجور يطرح انتشار احتجاجات
عماليه مشكله للحكومات فالانتاج يتعطل في
الوقت الذي تصرف فيه الحكومه المليارات في
محاوله للتخفيف من تاثير ارتفاع الاسعار
هذه الدهوك مراسل العربيه كان هناك
محطات المترو في باريس مقفله خميس اسود
تشهده البلاد بسبب اضراب ينظمهم موظفوا
قطاع الناقل تسبب بشلل تام في وسائل النقل
خطان فقط من اصل خمسه عشر من خطوط المترو
الفارسيه يعملان بشكل طبيعي لانهما
اوتوماتيكيان ولا يحتاجان اما الخطوط
المتبقيه فخمسه منها على الاقل توقفت بشكل
كامل فيما تعمل البقيه في ساعه فقط
ويتزامل هذا الاضراب الذي يحمل مطالب
زياده
انظر وتحسين ظروف العمل مع تظاهرات دعى
اليها الاتحاد العام للعمل وقال ان نحو
200 نقطه تظاهر خرجت في عمومي انحاء
البلاد استجابه لهذه الدعوه هذا الاضراب
متقرر ليوم واحد لكن امكانيه تمديده وجعله
اضراب المفتوحا هو امر وارد لكنه ينتظر
نتائج المفاوضات مع الحكومه سادده العربيه
باريس
[موسيقى]
اذا حركه المواصلات العامه في باريس واجهت
شلل جزئيا في الوقت الذي يتصاعد فيه غضب
المستخدمين لان الخدمات اصلا ما تزال
تعاني من التقليص منذ جاء احد كورونا اذا
لا تزال تعاني من ذلك العربيه التقت بعضا
من سكان باريس في يوم الاضراب هذا لتسالهم
على من يقع اللون في ما حدث على العمال
المغربيين ام على الحكومه الفرنسيه
تكون موتور ديسباسيتو
على الضفه الاخرى اضرب عمال مترو انفاق
العاصمه البريطانيه للمطالبه ايضا بتحسين
الاجور وهو الاضراب الذي ياتي بعد فشل
محادثات مع هيئه النقل في لندن قالت هيئه
النقل لانه من المتوقع ان يستمر الاضراب
حتى صباح غد الجمعه واوسط سكان بتجنب
السفر عبر مترو الانفاق والبحث عن وسائل
بديله هذا التحرك الاخير هو اخر حلقه في
سلسله اضرابات نقابيه الهدف منها واحد
تحسين الرواتب والمعاشات التقاعديه وظروف
العام لكن الحلقه المقبله من الاضطرابات
ستكون صعبه للغايه على البريطانيين ان
حدثت فالعاملون في قطاع التمريض في عموم
البلاد صوتوا لصالح تنظيم اضراب وطني
حسبما اعلنت نقابه الكليه الملكيه للتمريض
ار سي ان وحذرت النقابه من ان اكبر
مستشفيات انجلترا ستتاثر بالاضراب الذي من
المفترض ان يبدا قبل نهايه العام الحالي
وبينما لم تحدد النقابه طبيعه الاضراب بعد
الا ان كثيره بالتاكيد سيطالوا المرضى
الذين يعانون اساسا من لوائح انتظار
قياسيه واضطرابا في العمليات والمواعيد
دانت الكليه الملكيه للتمريض ظروف العمل
وتدني رواتب الممرضين والممرضات خلال
الاعوام الاخيره وطالبت بزياده الاجور
بنسبه 5%
بسبب نسبه التضخم الذي قفز باكثر من اثني
عشر بالمئه في سبتمبر وقد اظهر تحليل نشير
مؤخرا ان رتبه ممرض يملك خبره انخفض بنسبه
20% من قيمته الحقيقيه منذ عام 2010
[موسيقى]
احتجاجات وايران مستمره في اسبوع الثامن
ومجموعات كبيره من المواطنين تسير على خطى
الاحتجاجيه
لها على المعاناه التي يمر بها الاطباء في
ايران خلال التظاهرات المنتشره في البلاد
الصحيفه اشارت الى ان الاطباء كانوا من
بين اوائل المشككين في التفسير الرسمي في
منتصف سبتمبر عندما تحدثوا عن تعرضها
لردود وقصور قبل وفاتها منذ الايام الاولى
للاحتجاجات تمركزات قوته الامن داخل
المستشفيات للتعرف على المتظاهرين
واعتقالهم كما ضغطت على الطاقه الطبيه
للابلاغي عنهم لاحقا ومع تزايد الاعتقالات
بدا العديد من المتظاهرين بتجنب
المستشفيات ما دفع الاطباء الى تقديم
الرعايه داخل المنازل معرضين سلامتهم
ووظائفهم للخطر ومن لم يست توجه الى وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعيه لنشر مقاطع مصوره حول
كيفيه تنظيف الجروح وتضميضها والتعامل مع
الاصابات الاخطر كالجروح الناتجه عن طلقات
ناريه او طعنات العاملون في القطاع الطبي
لم يغيب عن التظاهرات وكانوا اقاموا نهايه
الشهر الماضي وقفه احتجاج للتمديد بوجود
قوه الامن في المستشفيات واعتقال وترهيب
زملائهم خلال الاحتجاجات
ختمت واشنطن بوست تقريرها هذا بمقابلات مع
اطباء في الداخل الايراني قالوا ان
الاطباء لا يختلفون عن بقيه شرائح المجتمع
الايرانيه وانهم يعانون نفس ما يعانيه
الاخرون وهم ايضا في الوقت ذاته انضموا
للاحتجاجات و سيدفعون الثمن
[تصفيق]
من لندن الباحث في الشان الايراني حسن
راضي اهلا بك معنا استاذ راديو اطلعت انا
لو سمحت على حقيقه تعاطي النظام مع هذه
الشريحه المهمه جدا في اي مجتمع شريحه
الاطباء تحديدا الى اي مدى يعاملون كغيرهم
من شرائح المجتمع ان كان ممن يتظاهرون
منهم او لا يفعلون ذلك
ليس بجديد انه النظام ايراني هكذا يتعامل
مع الاطباء ومع الممرضين حتى خاصه اولائك
الذين يعني عالجون الجرحى في المستشفيات
او في المطبات الخاصه همم حاجه ثانيه يعني
دائما النظام ايراني في كل الاحداث ويراقب
المستشفى ويراقب الصيدليات ويعاقب كل من
همم يعني اعالج همم الجرحى في الاحتجاجات
حتى يعني هو يوصل الاطباء والمستشفيات اي
جريح ياتي حتى الصيدليات هناك عيون للنظام
الايراني اي شخص ياتي ياخذ ادويه تتعلق
بالجراحات او غيرها يتم راقبته واعتقاله
انا اعتقد انه اليوم او في هذه الايام همم
يعني همم الادويه في ايران صعد سعرها
بنسبه 700
وبعض الادويه لا توجد ايضا الصيدليات مثل
الانتي بيوتي وانا اعتقد هذا من فعل
النظام تراني من اجل يعني مضايقه ماء من
يحتاجون مثل هكذا ادويه حتى يبقون دون
معالجه وبالتالي هم يعني التعرف عليهم او
غيرها يعني الالتهابات اذا كما تشير ولكن
هل يمكن ان تؤكد لنا ما ورد في تقرير
واشنطن بوست عن عزوف بعض المتظاهرين فعلا
همم عن توجه الى المستشفيات حتى لو
احتاجوها خوفا من الامن المتواجد في تلك
المستشفيات لانهم سيقومون باعتقالهم
اكيد يعني همم عندما تحصل همم مظاهرات
وايضا سقوط جرحه النظام ايراني يذهب الى
المستشفيات ويراقبها واي الجريح يذهب
ياخذون من المستشفى الى المعتقلات وهذه
حدثت في كل الاحتجاجات السابقه حصل هذا
ولدينا العديد من الذين يعني جروحه والنقل
والمستشفى تم اخذه من المستشفى الى
المعتقلات طبعا بشكل عام هذا يعني دائما
يحصل في ايران وخاصه في هذه الايام نعم
حتى الجريح لا يذهب الى المستشفى خوفا من
احتقاله واي طبيب او اي ممرض يقوم بمعالجه
اي جريح نتيجه المظاهرات همم الحاليه يتم
معاقبته يتم اعتقال طبيب او الجميع انه
مؤامره يعني يتامر مع النظام ويعمل ضد
النظام لصالح المعتدئي شكرا جزيلا على هذه
التوضيحات البحث الايراني حسن راضي من
لندن تحياتي اليك
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا لم ينجح اعصار ترامب
السياسي لكن اعصار نيكول نجح
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد السوق المتارجحه او
الشهيره بالتقلبات الهائله ثروات تظهر
وتختفي بين ليله وضحاها هل عرفتم عن اي
سوق نتحدث طبعا سوق العملات المشفره
متقلبه هي لكن ليس لدرجه ما حدث هذا
الاسبوع تبخرت شركه عملاقه او تكاد كما
تبخرت مليارات صاحبها ال 15 نتحدث عن شركه
اف تي اكس العملاقه وعن صاحبها سام بانك
من فرايد صاحب ال 30 عاما ان انهيار شو
بها ابن هيار بنك لمن براذرز عام 2008
الذي اثار ظهرا ماليا عالميا بل ازمه
عالميه لاحقا حاولت اكستفادي سقوط واعرضها
بنك مانشرايد على منافسه الصينيه
العملاقه باينهز بالفعل قبل الاخير العرض
ثم تراجع لتنهار امبراطوريه الرقميه
بايننس مع من اكبر البورصتين عالميا
عملياتها غامضه الى حد ما ليس لها مقر
رسمي وتسيطر حاليا على ما يقرب من نصف سوق
تبادل العملات المشفره ولها مشكله كبيره
مع بلدان عده في العالم اما اف تي اكس
فيقع مقرها الرئيس في جزر البهاماس حاول
مالكها استرضاء المشرعين الامريكيين واصبح
احد كبار المانحين الرئيسيين للحزب
الديمقراطي استثمر بعمله صنعتها واسمتها
افتيتي ووضعت اموال المستثمرين فيها وهو
امر عابه عليها قائلا لا نستخدم ابدا رمزا
قمت بانشائه كضمان
[موسيقى]
الغريب شركته باينس استثمرت مبكرا في شركه
اف تي اكس بل واشترى عددا كبيرا من رموز
ملياردير
في شركتهما الان يتنازعان رسميا على
احتواء السوق هذا
الوطن
وراء النشر
وخوفا من خساره اموالهم سحب المستثمرون
اكثر من سته مليارات دولار من بورصه اكس
على مدى ثلاثه ايام تاركين شركه تصارع
للحصول على السيوله لتغطيه الالتزاماتها
حاول موظفه
رساله اعتذار الى المستثمرين قال فيها انا
اسف لانني لم افعل ما هو افضل اثار
الانهيار المفاجاه الكثير من الاسئله
كمستقبل العملات المشفره ماذا سيحدث
لعملاء افت اكس مثلا ولاموالهم قد يترك
المستثمرون للقتال من اجل اموالهم او ما
تبقى منها في المحاكم ثم الاهم هل سيؤذن
انهيار اف تي اكس الى فشل اوسع في السوق
كما فعل انهيار لمن راديس في 2008 في
العالم ماليا حتى الان لا يعرف حجمه الضرر
الحقيقي فبالنظر الى ماذا تشابك افت اكس
مع بقيه اقتصاد العمله المشفره عند انتشار
اخبار افتي اكس ان انخفضت اسعار بيتكوين
وافيريوم على حد سواء وانخفض سعر العمره
العمله السولانه المشفره التي دعمتها افتي
اكس بنسبه 20%
[موسيقى]
لكن يبقى داعمون العملات المشفره يحدثهم
الامل بانه هو على عكس 2008 فان تداعيات
انهيار ستظل تحت السيطره في الغالب في
صناعه العملات الرقميه لكن لا يزال من
السابق لاوانه معرفه ذلك ايضا حتى هذا
الاسبوع
ملك العملات المشفره بلا منازع وقوه
متزايده في الولايات المتحده
مع 15 مليار دولار ثروه اليوم خسر الرجل
ما يصل الى
94% من ثروته اي لم يعد مليارديرا ولا
مؤثرا سياسيا هي نهايه رجل شجاع او شاب
شجاع الا اذا وصل سوق العملات المشفره
جنون
[موسيقى]
الى المزعج الرياضي الان مع محمد القناص
اليها
[موسيقى]
شكرا طاهر اخبار الرياضه حياكم الله اختتم
المنتخب السعودي مع سكره في ابو ظبي
بالتعادل امام منتخب فانا بهدف لمثلي على
ملعب ال نهيان فتح المنتخب
قبل التوجه الى الدوحه للمشاركه في كاس
العالم
هذا المهاجم عبد الرزاق حمد الله لتنفي
لمنتخب بلاده المشارك في المونديال بعد ان
نعلن وليد الرجراجي المدير الفني للمنتخب
المغربي القائمه النهائيه للاعبي والتي
ستشاركوا في كاس العالم في قطر كانت قرعه
المونديال وقعت منتخب المغرب الى جانب
المنتخبات بلجيكا كرواتيا وكندا شارك
منتخب اسود الاطلس في كاس العالم للمره
السادسه يعني افضل الانجازاته التاهل الى
الدور الثاني في نسخه عام 668
الى قائمه النهائيه لمنتخب البلجيكا في
مونديال قطر التي اعلنها اليوم المدرب
روبرتو مارتينيز ويعاني لوكاكو من اصابه
في الفخذ الايسر تسببت في تراجعي
مشاركاتهما انتر ميلان هذا الموسم حيث ظهر
في خمس مباريات فقط ويلعب منتخب بلجيكا
ضمن المجموعه السادسه للمونديال الى جانبي
كندا
اكد باولو بينتو مدرب منتخب كوريا
الجنوبيه ايناسيون هونج مين سيكون ضمن
تشكيله الفريق في نهايته كاس العالم التي
تنطلق في قطر بدا من العشرين من الشهر
الحالي مضيفا في مؤتمر صحفي انه ليس لديه
اي خطه بديله لم يكتمل التعافي المهاجم من
اصابه في الوجه في الوقت المناسب وسجل
سوني 35 هدفا مع منتخب كوريا والذي يبدا
مشواره في المونديال بمواجهه الاوروغواي
وستلعب وايضا ضد غانا والبرتغال في
المجموعه الثانيه
وقدم المنتخب البرتغالي فنادوا قدم المدرب
البرتغالي فناندو سانتوس الخميس قائمه من
26 لاعبا سيخوضون مونديال قطر على راسهم
مهاجم مانشستر يونايتد بالانجليزي
كريستيانو رونالدو وبعد شكوكو لفتره طويله
احياء جاهزيته بسبب التوائهم في الركبه
استدعي ايضا المدافع بي بي البالغ من
العمر 39 عاما غاب عن تشكيله المخضرم
ثاني اكثر اللاعبين مشاركه مع المنتخب بعد
رونالدو تلعب البرتغال في المجموعه
الثامنه مع غانا والاوروجواي وكوريا
الجنوبيه
اما منتخب المانيا يا قدم مصاعد يصوفا مو
كوكو وكذلك ديكلاس فلك للمره الاولى
لقائمه الفريق الذي يستعد للمشاركه في
مونديال قطر مشاهده القائمه التي اعلنها
المدرب تلك اليوم الخميس عوده مال القدس
صاحب هدف الفوز على الارجنتين في نهائي
مونديال البرازيل قبل 8 سنوات وجرس
استبعاده ماركو رويس قائد بروسيا دورتموند
26 لاعبا تلعب المانيا في المجموعه
الخامسه الى جانب كل من اسبانيا كوستاريكا
واليابان
وكشف مدرب منتخب بولندا عن قائمه من 26
لاعبا سيشاركون في مونديال قطر
يتقدمهم نجم برشلونه روبرت ليفاندوفسكي
تعملوا بولندا في عبور دوري المجموعات
لاول مره منذ مكسيكو 86 حيث تلعب في
المجموعه الثالثه مع السعوديه والارجنتين
والمكسيك
وانضم جيمس ماديسون الى قائمه المنتخب
الانجليزي في كاس العالم لكره القدم والتي
اعلنها المدرب جاره جديد واخر مشاركه لهما
مع المنتخب الى ما قبل ثلاثه اعوام تبدا
انجلترا في المونديال امام ايران في
المجموعه الثانيه
منتخب مصر يغيب عن المونديال لكن ذلك لا
يعني غياب المشاركه المصريه عام ان سيكون
المصري محمود ابو الرجال احد حكام كاس
العالم في قطر
يعني فخر لاي حد وشرف كبير جدا لاي حد ان
هو يروح يمثل بلده
وانا الممثل وحيد عيب كبير عليا لكن البشر
طبعا بالفخر ان انا حكم كنت باحلم وانا
صغير بشوف كاس العالم واتمنى ان انا اروح
احكم فيه ان انا ابقى موجود دلوقت انصاف
تحكام العالم دي حاجه كبيره جدا دائما هم
متابعينا عن طريق
البولر وعن طريق الجي بي اس ان هم
بيتابعوا التمرين بتاعنا والحمل بتاعه ايه
بيبعثوا لنا برامج همم مسؤول عننا في
الاتحاد الافريقي همم امباكي ده من
السنغال ده بتاع الفيس هو مسؤول الفتنس
بيتحل الفريكي وهو المفوض من الفيفا حتى
اللي بيجيء معنا البطولات بتاعه الفيفا
وهو دائما بيتابعنا وبيبعث لنا همم
البرامج وبيبعث لنا الملاحظات ايه وعلى
الواتساب طبيعي انا برده
كانت هذه ابرز اخبار رياضه وعوده الان الى
طاهر بركه استكمال العربيه 360
[موسيقى]
شكرا لمحمد في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360
عمليات السلام تعثرت بسبب الانتهاكات
المنهجا للقانون الدولي ومصادره الاراضي
وهدم المنازل والتوسع الاستيطاني وانتهاك
الحقوق وقتل الفلسطينيين هذه خلاصه تقرير
اصدرته لجنه الامم المتحده لحقوق الشعب
الفلسطيني السؤال ليس كيف سينتهي الحال
بهذا التقرير ففي الغالب سينتهي في صندوق
يضم عشرات التقارير الممثله لكن السؤال
كيف سيكون التقرير التالي واسرائيل تنتظر
اكثر حكومه يمنيه في تاريخها
فيديو اليوم حدث الاعصار الذي تحدث عن
الجمهوريون في الولايات المتحده حدث في
فلوريدا لكنه اعصار حقيقي هذه المره وليس
سياسيا تسببت سرعه رياح الاعصار نيكولي
التي تصل الى 120 كم في اصدار اوامر اخلاء
الزاميه لاربع مقاطعات ومن بين المتضررين
ترامب فزواج ابنته تفني والذي كان مقررا
هناك في منتجع مارغو شهير حكم عليه
بالتاجيل لم ينجح اعصار ترامب سياسي في
انجازي مهنته لكن اعصار نيكول ادى وظيفته
بنجاح
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من ماريو كوبيل
الاوكرانيه
تهيجيه صغيرتي فانا الجد الكسندر قادم
اليك يافيرونيكا كينا هو معا ككل اليوم
انا اسرع الخطا لكن سامحيني مره اولى
لانني اصبحت بطيء الخطا وها نحن ذا سلف
لعبتك المفضله على هذا الشاهد لكن سامحيني
مره ثانيه لانني لم اتي بالمزيد من
الالعاب فالالعاب في بلادنا صارت شحيحه
وسامحيني مره ثالثه مره اخيره لانني لم
اكن هناك حين سقط الصاروخ لم استطع ان
امنعه هذه هي الحرب الحرب المبيضه يا
جميلتي فيرونيكا تسامحي